the Joe Rogan experience I I found when
my when I changed my diet so radically
that my comfort foods changed and my
habits changed what I liked Gino a lot
of that is because I've got bacteria oh
I know that
oh yeah microbiome fascinating really
fascinating stuff and feeding back to
your brain you know that was the thing
that was so so strange
including your emotions yes very much so
but when I I became plant-based vegan
for health reasons and I wrote in my
book I wrote a lot of stuff about I am
an unethical vegan I'm not doing this or
any sort of animal any sort of animal
lack of animal cruelty nothing strictly
health that's why I'm doing the plants
and a story and this has happened to a
lot of friends of mine who change that
after whatever it takes and people are
guessing like three months four months
of of no animal products those little
critters eating [ __ ] in your in your
guts died that like the meat stuff and
they're not giving that feedback loop
and I just found a real emotional change
when all of a sudden I went I don't want
to be part of that of the suffering yeah
it was really strange how that changed
and it really felt to me I so want to I
you know hardcore atheist as you know
and I don't believe in a mind-body
separation at all and yet I seem to
believe that when I was 350 pounds that
none of that affected my emotion and
then I lost all this weight and found
there were so many changes in me that
seemed to be intellectual and emotional
and actually I had a lot of evidence
where physical well there's a lot me up
on the mind-body separation should [ __ ]
you up because a lot of people make
these assumptions that you know you are
not your body and a lot of very
intelligent people the issue working out
and they don't want to exercise and they
find it
like it's a vanity thing it seems
egotistical they don't they don't like
it and so they put it in this category
of kind of knucklehead dumb things to do
but your body in your mind are all in
the same house all the same thing yeah
if your house is filled with [ __ ] it
doesn't help and it was so amazing how I
mean I completely believe that yeah and
yet I wasn't livid that I was like
thinking that I was living this you know
2,000 year old idea of little homunculus
who's kind of living inside me who's
this pure pen and then the body is just
the vehicle it's driving around it well
it's not true help you with that I think
knowing you as long as I've known you
you're an intense thinker and you your
mind is something you I mean you cherish
your thoughts and you you embrace them
and you're a very intelligent guy and I
think you just probably rejected the
idea that there was anything outside of
the mind that had any influence on you
we also talked about this I was also you
know I was the biggest guy to ever go
through my school so my small high
school in western Massachusetts you know
so I was I was six seven and they wanted
me center of the basketball team they
want all this stuff and those kinds of
people in that kind of culture you know
I wanted to listen to music I wanted to
read and I set up this you guys who are
physical I don't like you I'm on a
different team yeah you know and my
dislike of competitions and teams became
a team thing yes you know yeah yeah
that's the thing you always get stuck in
yeah they did the dislike of teams
becomes your team and I'm trying so hard
now to think I have two choices one or
seven billion and there's no teams
between that I can either be myself or I
can be one of all humanity or I would
even say seven billion let's say a
hundred and eight billion the number of
people who have lived in history you
know those are the people I can be it's
why I'm trying to not and this is
impossible to do by the way I'm talking
about how I'm drew I'm explaining to you
how I'm driving myself crazy right I'm
not gonna get real information I'm
trying to not think
ever of us in them hmm but I'm trying to
say those of us who voted for Trump
those of us who believe this so it's
always us because man I am so [ __ ]
sick of teams yeah and even look back
and go you know I love the Velvet
Underground
I hated the [ __ ] Eagles and that was
a [ __ ] team and that was manipulated
and forced upon you know I mean I wanted
to be the kind of guy that went from you
know Zappa The Velvet Underground to to
Bob Dylan that was all okay and the
Eagles and the Doobie Brothers do not
what I listen to
I'm just trying to let that go yeah you
wanted to be one of the cool kids yeah
exactly yeah and whenever you want that
you've got to say well you're one of the
cool kids
that's the 108 billion who've lived on
this planet yeah that's a great way to
look at things and I think I wish people
taught that in school the dangers of
being involved in teams because we get
involved in teams in terms of like you
know you're playing basketball or
whatever but but teams in terms of like
the what what I believe versus what you
believe and I think we're experiencing
that politically right now with the most
polarizing time and in in my lifetime
that I've ever ever worldwide yes
worldwide I mean it's not it is not an
American thing right and it's just
insane and I also know that's why I said
you know I I try to go with the Velvet
Underground and the Eagles because
that's where I can really see where I'm
wrong yeah you know that I'm wrong how
do you deny victim of love that's a
[Applause]